guys we are about to watch the mortal
kombat
movie you excited john i am so excited
so here's the dealio hit that like
button
subscribe click that noti bell this is
reaction highlights
can't show the whole thing this probably
won't even be monetized dude
but we're making this just for you guys
it's full length reaction watch along
for yes
think of it with the time code or over
at our patreon page where we got shows
like supernatural
doctor who and a bunch of other shows as
well
try to read all these titles the best
you can right then and therefore
watch that for mortal kombat snyder cut
some other movies as well are all over
there thank you to everyone who's joined
our patreon page believe me when i
say that you know sometimes we do put up
these videos that are not monetized
you guys a patreon help us bounce back
every time so thank you
and also gotta thank lisa m esslinger
for
helping to edit these reaction
highlights for us she is the apprentice
of eric then record
a man who normally helps us edit the
reaction highlights for movies and tv
shows
so thank you so much my dear you rock
but yeah guys
i've been doing so much research on
mortal kombat leading into this
learning all about guile and his partner
losing so that's why he has his vendetta
with bison
ryu and ken ryu and sagat whoa wait dude
dude
those are street fighter characters
they are yeah were you one of those
people upset that chun li is not in this
movie
yeah ah what the [ __ ]
a little kid's in on it
the rat it's leaking secret
who sent sub-zero's gang in there huh
this is way too damn positive for what's
coming
this is just the best most idyllic day
oh is it is that a cane she was dinner
with yeah
yeah not a simple gardening tool
really emphasizing it yeah he will use
this
i'm a baby
oh it's like the scorpion's revenge
cartoon that's cool
[Music]
hmm
i like how the subtitles are making it
clear which language you're speaking
ah that does look painful damn geez
[Music]
no dude oh you know it's coming though
damn
effort grunt
all that hard work it's crazy we're
watching a mortal kombat movie
i know it feels like a real movie it's
just so weird
oh no oh man
oh oh
heavens that is tragic
oh yeah they're not gone yet
i mean it's him they want
that's some cool revenge
yeah yeah i've been waiting
all my life to use this for this purpose
nice ah yes oh
oh man oh man
yo he pulled it
you're being a dick this is wondering
can he understand him
now finish him no
oh god ow
oh
i love this music
oh is that promo shot
he's going to find your ass in the
tournament no
way he's still alive
this is hell oh
ah how interesting
come with me to the future baby
sweet
yeah who did the music for this i was
just wondering that
it better not be chunky xl again
there you go
cole young yeah that was cool young wow
okay
i guess my predictions go you're really
really fast 17th century
citizen cage in the background
jack still got his arms okay yeah oh
we're gonna we're gonna see
that
they should call this fight yeah this
guy's going to die
sound effects man
you're gonna do great immortal combat
cole you're doing amazing
you might even think back to this moment
go now and kill earth realms champions
he's gonna spend the whole movie
convincing people that guys guys
[Laughter]
he's like the one character in recent
memory seems to have just chosen his own
name
[Laughter]
your blood lineage your literature is
coming to call you man
the twist is calling you
god says it was already pretty freaking
entertaining yeah i know
and we've already got two fights
cole young the man that took the belt
from eddie tobias
that dragon logo you got i i think that
man it's a birthmark
you serious pretty cool that one looks
way better
works way better that way how'd he go
he was this close to being this
oh they still love him dude you sure
you're okay
standing i mean you look pretty good
because all things considered
heal fast yeah you don't look
got my ass on him right now he's got the
mark i saw it
sub-zero's coming to town oh
it's gonna have a name tag that says my
name is sub zero
[Laughter]
oh no not the ketchup i can't wait to
see the corridor crew
video about all these ice effects
oh no oh god
oh what a dick move yeah
if you heart one hair on her head
leave your wife and kids they don't get
to come along they're not chosen
they're not the mark
yeah you would have been better off just
sneaking up on them
you could add them all dead by now
[Applause]
no it didn't it's a good point
he's got the tattoo it's a birthmark i
was born with it
take the truck to safety
see for some reason i thought when we
first see jax he'd we could do a
flashback when he lost his arms that's
what i thought
yeah yeah like this is when i first ran
into him or whatever
hold on tight guys we got a new car
do you think he's going to want this
back
oh no it's coming yeah
what a great shot oh
look at his outfit damn
i don't want to watch i like jax's arms
oh man poor guy
oh gross
oh there's bones sticking out
oh ow i will call you
daddy instead of sub-zero call you
whatever you
[Laughter]
he's lethal yeah jax is definitely gonna
need some
some cyborg [ __ ] to get through that
like 25 minutes and this is so exciting
three fights i should go
jax could have killed it
jax is our best friend we love you
jack's car
we didn't win nine straight tournaments
by following the rules
let's finish this dude there's messed up
okay
front row was just you showing off
you need to do that i didn't need the
front roll
no one's watching you right now he
improvised that freaking lewis tan
american music player military drums
model slash military and not the other
way around
jax where are you
he he can't text right now
maybe he has dictation turned
the on had the same marking
when jax finally took it down the dragon
mark can transfer directly onto his skin
i've spent years trying to figure out ah
okay what is this you have a visitor
carefully bites
oh he really does have a prisoner okay
you know what
can i none of you
[Laughter]
what about you where's your marking i
don't have one
you get a lot of scraping
reptile reptile
i think kano's about to step up
ah origins of the eye
oh grossy gross gross gross
ah clever
clever
wow
cool
oh there you go there you go
i bet that shot got cut down for the
rating
poor coal you just have it a day
yeah a couple hours ago as a normal mma
fighter
killed it
[Laughter]
you know where that is what's raiden's
temple yeah i used to run guns through
there
locals wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up legend
says champions used to train there for
immortal combat
no one knows where it is literally he
does
yeah i'm a popular guy everyone loves me
no no i'm not
don't ruin it with a spit you're gonna
give that guy three million dollars
[ __ ] no i live in this [ __ ] hole you
think i got three million dollars
i just wouldn't say it's so loud your
special forces you know better [ __ ]
probably has
paper than this yeah i thought the
window was open for a second door's open
i really like the guy who plays kano
yeah
he's just dreaming about
that's as hell journey like you do
there's a good amount of f words in this
movie yeah there's a whole bunch
it's giving us everything we want
28 k's only 30 to be safe
straight up for 32 right we say 35
they'll be nice
[Laughter]
you don't enjoy
number six come on sonia you're a badass
oh yo yeah she would whoop your ass oh
my gosh
yeah that's why you don't have one of
these
she's like batman what only separates
her from kano is she won't take his life
right that's the joker right here
lou king
oh this is to be all about mortal kombat
it is
he's probably betrayed raiden
oh nice
there's much
it's all real these murals are the
living history of mortal kombat
oh now this one really
that's got to be foreshadowing this is
our world
yes shao khan most brutal and murderers
of all the realms they murder her a lot
their murray murdery world it used to be
called murder realm
come on
oh my god jax made it to raiden's temple
he hitchhiked all the way there
[Laughter]
by the that was too time
he didn't really find anyone else
a lot of champions biting the dust
lately
the ice cauterizes wounds it's crazy
same thing that took his arms
also saved his life yeah give them time
to do their work
give them time to do some next level
robotics
[Laughter]
i mean you really just held over the
entrance door they found you my name
you don't even have a mug hey man she's
been kicking ass
oh damn an outward will gain control
over earth
forever yo you are not an optimist
wow very cynical race trying to motivate
them
by making them realize how heavy the
odds are i'm willing to die for my
family
i mean all the other champions have died
what the hell how is he so good at
finding everyone
you can probably communicate with the
water or something
oh god guys dick moved
and the other shot they were right next
to each other then they cut and they
were
they were like we got haunted oh they
gonna fight
sub-zero's the name just in case anybody
missed that
man chiang sang and his team are a bunch
of
uh could be a bullies hat you know no
offense whoever you are
the point of your training is for you to
unlock that power
without it defeating our world will be
impossible
it feels like i'm watching an animated
movie yeah a little bit
it was just now love how sub-zero
shakespeare just showed up
yeah i know it's not there anymore
yeah that lightning wall is very
effective without an akana
is a liability to know this yeah
liability
way to traditional loo justice for sonia
blade
what happened you remember anything all
you can do now is test your might
touch your mind
dude don't go full all out you might
kill him before
mortal kombat oh i'm afraid you're gonna
hurt him too much i know
wow he has muscles
he is really whoa oh my god
no harry potter let's see
go down again
it's like you're fighting a video game
we're just doing the same move
[Laughter]
major i've seen better than that
again again oh it looks like baby jacks
yeah how's it on it's healing up
eat more oh my arm hurts yeah you know
what i mean jackson
wow man that arm that wound on your arm
looks pretty nasty boy
i'm wanted in over 35 countries for [ __ ]
you [ __ ] ballerinas couldn't even
imagine
you're angry oh [ __ ] nothing gets by you
does it
you should be you're failure
value well they're just trading him huh
yeah
what's cano's childhood like it was
really nice
here it comes here it comes
[Music]
that was it wasn't it you all saw that
[Laughter]
ah laser beam
such an [ __ ] oh my god
focus on what you can't deny
find the truth in you how about raiden's
doing no generating
come on cole for centuries
the hostage mocking has passed down
through your ancestors
i had a hope the power in your bloodline
was too strong in you
now i know that's not the case my god
raiden
you are not an optimist
that's that's their school of training
just make them feel as worthless as
possible until that arcana wakes up
oh cole failed mortal kombat training
and now i gotta live the rest of my life
on the run
oh wow wow wow wow
wow natara
oh no damn
outworld looks like a boring ass place
what are you guys that's why they wanted
earth so bad yeah
like we got to get out of here these
rocks and a big door
rocks like purple gray you
just stand around
you can turn this old temple into your
own casino if you wanted to
just name your price then double it and
double it
are you waiting for [ __ ]
so what would i need to do oh come on
one security camera there yeah that's
something sanctum santorum we don't have
wi-fi
oh it's arcana time huh it's arcana time
wait are we never going to get to we
actually better get to actual internal
combat
the tournament must begin it's like
we're over an hour into this movie
oh no goro just showed up to his home
oh wow
oh no
i need to wear something yellow
ah four jacks dude
oh no oh ah
women fight women yeah they have to
thing to say oh what um
[Applause]
there's a lot of green ooh cool
[Music]
wins
don't hurt the thing cole cares about
dude his family
oh there it is
oh my god he's get a super suit he's
gonna become aquaman
[Laughter]
use that energy
oh
got even the score there had a little
bit of the theme song in it
god come on cole
yeah dad go for it yes
no one makes me sleepy
still coaching him on the side
oh man kano gets one little laser beam
and
nicole gets an outfit weapon
energy absorbing power
nice good [ __ ] cole oh [ __ ] wait dude no
i'm sorry
oh oh my god oh
i love you so much ted let me get blood
all over you guys you're the best
husband ever
badass dad cause the family just
stopped questioning things you know he
saved the day
ever since jax came i stopped
questioning a single thing yep
not freaked out just used to this life
find your arcana jacks
no way oh my god
[Music]
his arms are
arcana linked our cannon can do anything
i know kano's laser jax's
arms let's say our cannon has gotten
really good at like metal working and
electronics
his arms are spiritually linked doesn't
go way back
it's not over it hasn't even begun yeah
be hot
[Laughter]
you don't know me but we're rivals
no
don't turn him into a prune it's pretty
cool it's green though like this
oh no oh
no kung lao
over the hakka or just the hat one with
them i
i guess shan soon cannot follow us here
we live here now
all is lost kung lao better like claws
way back out of shank so
[Music]
we need to fight smarter we need to
split them up
give me raikou i gotta score this how do
you know his name
this is cool to go to like fighting
levels yeah that's pretty cool
that's i like that that's that's neat i
know i've seen you kick his ass before
but he's got a laser now
watch out for that no i got an idea
come on sonia we saved subzero for last
you take him out together
as a team
kohl's leader now dude
nice oh here we go
oh damn
oh
yeah these [ __ ] work
yes that was so gross
that was the most satisfying head
explosion i've seen in a long
time
oh nice
oh there you go
[Music]
oh
poetic
ah she gets it there you go you earned
it hell yeah sonia blade
now the fight begins for you
bring the dragon yeah bring the dragon
how do we make this flow yeah
[Music]
nice
hey they gave it to her
oh she was gonna show up
sub-zero you slasher villain you yeah
seriously
he is this whole movie
hmm oh
[Music]
damn oh
[ __ ] no
yes
music yes nice that sounds good
i learned english in hell
you know scorpio i mean sub-zero learned
english too so
oh nice
little black splotch flat on the sword
that's cool
he did one of his frozen duplicates
yeah i was gonna say he's gotta be
flashing back
oh nice working working together
don't just give up man backs against the
ropes come on
oh oh
do a finishing move nah he deserves the
final kill
yeah nice
and there's to work it in
is he gonna get dusted
i don't speak japanese i don't know what
any of that was about
a group in chicago
this will do it
he needs more blankets my day's fighting
for 200 bucks or done
now you're finally quitting huh yeah uh
something like that where are you gonna
go
hollywood hollywood johnny cage
it's been fun oh my god they got matthew
mcconaughey
do oh yeah and then we got the 2021
updated remix
hey look we got mics oh we're back so uh
yeah we actually shot that reaction
a little bit ago in that time span we
put out our immediate reaction review
where we
got on our phone and you can watch that
video all that being said
and i mean this sincerely because i know
we like had a lot of positive say that
we had a lot of criticisms to say
all that being said i think for laying
the groundwork
setting up the seeds for a franchise for
a part one installment where you can do
a part two
take more time do what you really want
to get expand the runtime
make sure you can uh really flush out
the characters that much more and it
ends on a note that gets you excited for
a sequel and i think it ought to get a
sequel i think i still think it deserves
one regardless
and it was great as someone who is half
asian to see a bunch of asian
representation on screen it was awesome
see
and there was one white guy for me one
white guy for jesus
even though i definitely have my
criticisms about it i think it's a great
step in the right direction especially
for video game movies
and it's really freaking it's [ __ ]
entertaining yeah it's entertaining all
right it's really entertaining
they hit the mark about as much as they
needed to and yeah this seems like a
good
solid step in the right direction for
video game movies but still with room to
improve kind of
kind of like tomb raider in the sense of
like the alicia vikander one it's like
it does a lot
gets it right could be a little more
unique but you know this is a good start
and i would love to see a sequel yeah
end of the day what all you guys were
saying in the comments of what you
wanted a movie to deliver on
a hundred percent it does and then
there's other stuff around it in terms
of filmmaking and storytelling that you
could criticize
but great first step and i mean that
sincerely with snyder cut we put that
at the end of our part six of the snyder
cut reaction
i thought it was like a cool full circle
and then uh then i regretted
that and i was like that's kind of
stupid and a waste of time it's just
like inserting an older video
like i didn't see any complaints about
it but in my personal paint i was stupid
so i was like
all right well why don't we just like
add a little bit more here
our general thoughts on it because like
we actually shot on the phone
while the credits were rolling way past
the credits it was like talk for like 24
minutes
and the video that's up on youtube was
like 13 minutes and in that time frame
we covered a video that was comparing
1995 to 2021
and then we even cover new rockstars
easter eggs and breakdown videos so
we've kind of talked a lot about mortal
kombat
so far so i'm like what can we really
add to here
right now that we haven't said before
because i know there's some people who
haven't seen those videos and there's
some people who've already seen it or
like wasn't one of me sticking around
so i guess for this one like what we can
talk about is like in our non-spoiler
one that we put up on youtube already
we mainly leaned into the positives of
things you know like
the action actors brought a lot of
personality i think there's a lot of
cool camera work here i do think the
choreography tops
the 95 movie despite what i've seen some
people say the choreography specifically
as i'm talking about i think there's a
lot of very inventive things with their
action scenes and even watching like the
new rock stars breakdown made me
appreciate the
attention to detail that much more that
sprinkled in throughout that i
i feel like i overlooked even during the
reaction and yeah the gore in the
violence is really great
but i don't know maybe kind of use this
time to maybe dive into a little bit of
i don't know how little gripes it that
we couldn't really go into detail about
so yeah i'll see how this goes i watched
the movie
again so that way i was like well how do
i really
feel about this movie like do i really
like it a lot and i would say that i
would get this movie like
i want to say like a 6.8
okay that's fair yeah i'd probably go a
little higher than you and maybe go
like a seven or something like that like
you know wow
seven or six point eight yeah man this
is a
real pitch fork of a debate right jesus
christ john
all those points those two tenths of a
point are real
significant you beast here that's right
man
um and i i feel like i mean the short
version of of like
of the review was that we i i personally
really enjoyed like the for everything
leading up to raiden's temple
and then like the first few minutes from
raiden's temple and then
it was really the stuff there up until
we finally
got to the finale with like goro and
then shang sun and subs
like when we're starting into like the
level battles and all that stuff after
cole young gets his literal plot armor
after all that happens uh it was like in
between there was where there was like
chunks and little bits and pieces that i
i wasn't a big fan of and it dawned on
me in the second viewing
what it was and i've mentioned this in
another video was that the world here
should
feel bigger and it should feel more
lived in
and on the second viewing i was like
this this kind of feels like a
play with mortal kombat characters
yeah it's like we keep talking about big
world events
doesn't take over and i think to the
scene when shang sun is like the great
natara
prince goro cabal it was that there's
like a legend behind these people
yeah like what all i see is them and i
don't really get the presents or what
influence that like
formidable presence isn't really felt
beyond the titles yeah and like without
world i'm like is this a
all you rule in is is out like the movie
should communicate it
some people go well you should play the
game so that way you like really totally
you know like you understand what's
going on i'm like well that's exactly
100 based off the game though cole
young's not in the games
little archon of things a little
ridiculous like what jack's getting is
like
cyber like to me the movie is
incredibly i think the movie's really
fun like the first
40 minutes i i do think is really fun
even when the dialogue is weak and when
it's cheesy or just super on the nose i
have a lot of fun when i watch this
movie and the gore is entertaining as
hell and also say someone said in our
watch along on patreon
like there's not that many action scenes
unless you're chatting with these little
squabbles
okay you know what i would say any
moment that is like
more than 20 to 30 seconds that involves
you know
fighting blocking your camera and
choreography and stunt work
maybe there's not full-on action scenes
throughout
but there's a lot of action i would say
yeah throughout you know yeah yeah there
may be
a lesser count of like full-on focal set
pieces that take up
several minutes on end or whatever but
it does feel like throughout the movie
there is action and getting from place
to place usually involves a skirmish of
some kind so
yeah if you want to split hairs perhaps
the actual set pieces are less numerous
but there's
it still felt to me like they packed the
movie with action like they never went
too long without action
oh no there's little bits even in
raiden's temple it's like we're going to
go train like
we're going to try and like spare people
off that's what i mean like the training
to me didn't feel like anything too
special yeah i felt like the training
had felt more special like i didn't feel
urgent
uh yeah i guess that's a good way to put
it i just feel like the actual training
in and of itself like
that's what i mean there's bits about it
that i like that are pay homage to the
game
like when liu kang keeps sweeping kano's
legs yes that's super enjoyable
yes or when kano is uh heavily provoked
by kung lao uh
primarily at the dinner table and as
arcana unleashes and his
laser eye comes out i really love that
scene
raiden to me i'm like you got shang sun
who was the representation of our world
and then in earth realm you got raiden
but raiden kind of just feels like he
doesn't even want to be in the movie
feels like he's over it and he doesn't
have any faith in his team
except for maybe lukang and kung lao and
he's left everything up to them
yeah like i personally and this can be
said i think of a lot of the different
characters like i liked that
actor i thought he brought presents
however
yeah rayden isn't that much of a
character and it feels like
a lot of the guidance and a lot of the
tutelage that ought to come from a
character like that at least in the way
this story is set up does
again fall onto kung lao and uh liu kang
especially
yeah i mean like the fir this movie is
kind of misleading from its opening
scene
because the opening scene i think is
still the best part of this whole movie
yeah are going to say the kung lao
fatality which is the best fatality
i mean yeah but yeah like the opening
scene is a full-on
scene sequence yeah that that opening
scene
gets you emotionally hooked into hanzo
his family i thought that was captured
very well and it did feel like you're
watching
like a historical martial arts drama
yeah like a martial arts epic yeah and i
like the subtle use and the attention to
detail on uh
uh oh my god i'm blanking on his name
right now i know it's sub-zero but
behind
yeah damn it all right uh with bihan and
like the subtle use of
his hands like the ice coming into
fruition like i really
love that opening scene it's great and
then i think it's really fun up until we
get to raiden's temple where it kind of
feels like it slows down
uh quite a bit when we're there because
the the training sequences feel like i
think the action is very inventive
but in in raiden's temple that the
training is not that inventive that's
how you put it
yeah and also i feel like those scenes
are there to give an excuse to create
more match-ups between
characters who are on the same team so
we do training so that they don't have
to actually fight each other for plot
reasons you know we give the fans some
service that way
however yeah i feel like if they had
made those feel
a bit more urgent or or colorful or
something like it does feel like we're
sort of biting time until the next part
of the plot kicks in
a little bit which undercuts just the
oomph of some of that even though the
scenes individually the
the match-ups and some of the banter is
still amusing you know well it's mainly
spliced in
with either a lot of exposition or just
the
the the basics we need to get out of the
way
for uh you know like some little
character things like oh jax is sad
about his arms
and everyone else is kicking ass right
now and he's just over here recovering
and cole young um having a lack of faith
in himself
i i really feel like this could have
used like an extra
i i heard there was a lot cut i believe
that it feels that in the second viewing
i was like oh yeah i could feel that
there's like
a lot of things that could have really
helped let this breathe
yeah and be fleshed out and there's
certain scenes that feel like they were
supposed to continue
uh-huh yeah and i mean when i say that i
think
that they should get a sequel and i feel
like they can definitely improve upon it
i just want to be able to have instead
of being told so i'm being told a lot
about the world i'm not really feeling
the world
it kind of feels like they filmed like a
really good looking fan film
hey i think we i mean you go back to our
interview and i mean that's pretty much
what uh
greg russo the writer even said was you
know they basically let us make a big
fan film and in some ways i think
that is a good thing because there are
some of those really fanservicey
pulp and classic mk elements that come
out but also there is like i was
thinking during this conversation
another thing about outworld that i
think could have been improved upon is
the fact that to me
every time we cut to outworld it feels
like we're cutting to a desert on earth
and i feel like to really feel like this
is like an
other realm of existence you know
parallel to our own universe or at least
adjacent to it
like i felt like they could have made it
feel somehow more sci-fi like
i thought they really kept the kung fu
like the martial arts
movie the martial arts action movie
stuff going pretty well
but having it be you know i think that's
something a sequel could improve upon in
a realistic way because i feel like in a
lot of ways this movie has the thankless
job of going
okay this can work in a way that's not
gonna be a meme
and that people can take at least
somewhat seriously and this can set up
for a legitimate franchise and so i feel
like that's kind of why we wound up with
a story about
cole young regular human mma fighter guy
thrust into this world and then has to
save earth with the rest of the earth
people he's our cipher
i feel like maybe what the ideal moral
combat live action movie i didn't need
that
i know but i'm saying no no i i know and
i think the ideal mk movie would be
something more akin to the scorpion's
revenge animated movie which
takes like there are similar plotting
elements to how that movie needs to
sort of solve its problems and even
bookending aspects of
i mean that movie has a lot more of the
scorpion sub-zero story
and also it has twists upon that
i feel like you know for the average
movie girl john's way of telling me he
finally saw a scorpion that's right dog
just wouldn't tell me beforehand we take
so many things yeah i've already seen
him no
like you finally all the moral
videos you put out and this is your way
of finally telling me
whatever is this next time i'm gonna i'm
gonna text you the second i finish
something like this um but no i feel
like for a lot of fans out there who are
already familiar with the game and
already saw the original movie
like for all the people who aren't
uninitiated and in need of convincing i
feel like that would have been the ideal
moral combat movie and there are
bits and pieces of this movie that do
sort of resemble that and i feel like
because
there's all this debate about like if
you know the games really well you'll
like it and if you don't i don't know
but i feel like that was the whole
reason of
like because the the cul young
protagonist basically feels like a thing
the studio needed to have
in order to appeal as broadly as
possible whereas if you just threw it in
like a fantasy martial arts epic that it
truly
is you know that's a harder sell off the
bat
i feel like well i i think like some of
the
cinematic storytelling angles have more
flavor and tone and personality and more
life to them
in in the games absolutely actual
cinematic scenes that's the irony is
that in doing this
they create a plot line that is kind of
like a 90s
video game adaptation because there's
always like oh we got to put like a
regular human protagonist for us to
cipher in with
and yeah it's like ironically i don't
think they need it as
much these days because you know yeah
i think sometimes it can fall a little
bit flat because
to be honest the stakes of what
mortal combat like what mortal combat
represents i'm not talking thematically
like
what actual mortal combat is yes
i don't feel those stakes at
all no the the movie's trying to avoid
having mortal kombat
and i think like that would have helped
telling the audience beforehand that
mortal kombat are gonna happen in this
like like i saw 3c films review of
mortal kombat and he just tells the
audience like look there's no mortal
kombat in this movie yeah
you don't actually go there and like if
you've seen our reaction
i i don't know if in the highlights or
not but i remember being like damn it's
kind of disappointing we don't actually
go to mortal kombat and they don't
[ __ ] prep you in the in the
marketing or the lead-up to this that
it's a preak that it's supposed to be
like a prequel to mortal kombat or
setting you up going to the event the
movie's called mortal kombat
you think you're going to the tournament
i keep talking about this tournament
that i don't
feel like yeah you're just saying like
the most generic stuff when we cut to
shang tsung and out world about [ __ ]
like taking over earth and i'm just yeah
like
i don't really feel the why behind so
much like
i'm knowing the goals i'm getting the
end goal about everything but i don't
know
why to care about these people or why
the stakes are
big other than the generic of like we'll
take over earth but i feel like there's
like five locations in this movie
yeah and it's weird because shang tsung
seems
both over it but also kind of desperate
he's like i don't want to do
we've won all no like nine consecutive
mortals combat
and uh i don't want to do this last one
i want to cheat my way out of it so i
can avoid it entirely
it is perhaps my biggest gripe about the
movie
although i feel like with that out of
the way it'll be very easy
perhaps in the next movie to just go
right to mortal kombat and to really be
in the fantasy of that and to maybe
expand upon that you know i'm in
conflict with the characters at times
i'm watching this because you can have
two versions of this movie you can just
look at it and go
it's fun it's entertaining
and yeah maybe if you do play the games
you'll appreciate it more
or maybe you'll get upset by some of the
things they change you know
i don't know which way as a is a game
player you would you would go about this
seeing some of the the costumes brought
to life and i feel like there's there
are some actors who
bring a lot guy plays jax i think it
brings a lot scorpion and sub-zero
a plus casting in my opinion i think
they're
solid top-notch 100 more than just their
fighting like they're perfect
they chose yeah it's funny that they
don't have as many acting scenes because
those guys can both
act as well yeah i just wanted a live
action scorpion's revenge that had a
little bit more dramatic
yeah but you know like i gotta be honest
about louis tan you know like i i don't
think he does that good of a job in his
acting in this movie like i think i
think some scenes he's fine but then
there's other
times where it really feels like
beginner's acting
and i i think if you're in uh you know
he's a better actor than me i guess
but but if you're the lead of mortal
kombat you're the lead of a warner
brothers movie i think
i i expect you to be better that's kind
of just my
mentality about it that's not unfair
like especially
it really dawned on me during the the
like the more high intense emotional
dialogue deliveries times like if it's
if he has to be kind of cool
and deliver his like when he's hanging
out with his daughter in the beginning
or being a little cold you know like a
little rough
you know bad yes but when he's like has
to get like high intensity when jax is
like get in the car
yeah yeah what's going on or when goro
shows up his
acting in the bigger scenes and the
scenes that require more
like more emotion yeah i i don't think
he does uh that good of a job in those
things
i i yeah i can't entirely disagree i i
do
his i find his charisma appealing but he
does seem
suited to the kind of movie this is
trying to transcend
and so i feel like it partially fits
because
the movie is partially that movie
whereas you know you're taking this
fantasy and you're crashing it into like
oh yeah
again earth protagonist regular guy but
uh
yeah i mean surrounded by all these
other more colorful characters and
especially on
you know returning to the film he does
get sort of drowned in the color and in
the little nuances a lot of the other
people around him bring
well i don't know tony sometimes i think
the movie is a little bit
uh at odds with itself tonally what it
wants to
be like really committed to providing
more nuance
the beginning the final fight the kano
uh kung lao going toe-to-toe with each
other scene
like those moments i think hit and then
there's other times where i'm like
but wait are you trying to also be like
[ __ ] it it's a fun movie you know
yeah yeah sometimes i can't tell it's
like that first opening scene
sets you up for a very different tonally
yeah and then it's transitioning you
it's like when you cut to
cole young it's not like goofy it's
still serious and weight like i really
like the pulse of when you know
sub-zero shows up and then jax is like
shows up and
they're all the way to get and that's
what i mean when it gets to raiden's
temple is and then you're cutting back
fortune raid and temple and outworld
is when some of the drag starts to be
felt and the world starts to shrink
and i that's like my my biggest
complaint about the flick is that it
actually becomes less interesting to me
it becomes fun again in the finale
but there's that middle chunk where i'm
like you're telling me a lot of
information
a lot of wooden acting here and the
fights are
all right yeah the sub-zero scorpion
stuff is like the best part but it's
also not
the most prominent part of this movie no
no no
although i mean it does certainly leave
a better impress like it
it didn't i didn't leave me upset like i
was pleased with what we did get and i
certainly
wanted more uh and i hope that in the
sequel they will find a way to do more
and i'm sure that there are
i mean there are ways within the lord
that that can happen and i wouldn't be
at all surprised if they find a way to
re-contextualize sub-zero so that it
wasn't really him
or whatever you know in the events of
this movie
uh what are you talking about i don't
know
what are you doing trying to just fit in
some scorpions revenge plotline stuff
here
i'm not trying to show off my knowledge
of that movie i was just like this is a
relevant time to bring it
i don't know this is like there's a
relevant time to talk about it
very epic and sub-zero is the one who
killed
uh scorpions family in this one yeah uh
on behalf of shang tsung it seems like
yeah yeah but they can always
recon things sure why not we only saw
that opening scene from a certain
perspective in this movie
i think it's trying to like it's trying
to have you care about so much but like
i i don't think the
i don't think that's another thing with
cole young i don't think he has
chemistry with anyone yeah
that's also fair i mean he kind of
chemistry with his daughter but everyone
else i don't think he has chemistry
a lot of the character and that's part
of the hitch in the get-along is that a
lot of the other cast at least kind of
does form an ensemble or at least
they'll have chemistry they'll have a
rapport
they're pairs or whatever but i heard
somebody say that one of the flaws in
this movie is it doesn't feel like it
has a protagonist
and i can kind of see what they mean
like part of me goes well
it's sort of an ensemble but then i'm
also like well it's also trying to
thrust a specific
protagonist onto you and i yeah i don't
think it lands
truly on one of those things and i feel
like that kind of tampers with the
emotional resonance too
oh yeah i think there's a lot of poor
scripting um in terms of like structure
because like you got hanzo who gets
killed off in the beginning
and you get like these cut twos of just
like these little flashes
of uh cole young seeing him in hell oh
yeah and then he just comes back at the
end for a fight and i'm like
i really want a real build up to this
sub-zero in scorpio fire just kind of
like us a lot of the trailer when's it
coming
yeah yeah and i wonder if if that was
ultimately
something that changed a lot over the
course of the production too because
just the things like that like that like
oh just put in a flash of scorpion like
every 10 minutes
you know feels like a studio note to be
like uh we're building up to this thing
that we all know is coming
yeah i think i i had more it's weird to
kind of just throw this into the
reaction
video but i had more fun the first time
i watched this movie
for sure i think it shows in the
reaction and the second time i watched
it where i'm like all right i know what
to expect i know what i had fun with
i know i feel like i had some criticisms
i want to be able to feel a little bit
more of those out so i can kind of talk
about them
and i mean i'm not just saying it i
think that they could do a sequel that
would be much better
and i think they have like the
groundwork to do it you got a lot to
build on yeah
yeah and they get there's enough in this
movie that works and that is cool that
yeah you could easily
it's like i'm not concerned cole young
is like the danny rand of this movie
i am except he can fight except like
except he can actually sell them like
louis ironically is in iron fist and and
he has like a scene stealing scene like
he
he can act the guy can act okay i'm not
going to say cole i'm not going to say
lewis thing can't act he can act i just
don't think in this movie he does
that great of a job but i think like in
the other stuff i've seen i mean you
could definitely act
i think it's important no absolutely
absolutely and i mean that is
an important element because i feel like
in a lot of ways yeah
if this same team was to make the next
movie i would feel like okay they're
pretty competent hands because as
what this movie is i think it's it's
made whether you like pacing or
or plotting issues aside just the the
construction of it physically
is really sleek and punchy and well done
and so yeah if we could fix
uh that character element because you
know there are a lot of directors
certainly who favor
the visual and the aural over the actual
you know acting and subtext or whatever
but yeah i mean i feel like that's
something that could be built upon and
hopefully doesn't need to rely
as much and as heavily on just the
actors bringing
the personality to the characters i
think the emotional meat underneath just
needs to be felt more
you know yeah the bones of that that
just that needs to be felt more
because all that stuff can be pulpy too
like it doesn't necessarily have to be
like the most
world-gripping problems that these
characters say it doesn't need to be
like a story about grief in the marvel
cinematic universe
you know but it's hard it's hard to know
what my heart should be attached to
or feel for or care for in like uh i
don't know how like this movie is like a
little under
two hours a little under two hours but
you got like 14 characters in here
you know yeah for sure but you can pull
it off even in that time frame
you know uh but it's like i mean this is
longer than i would have expected a
mortal kombat movie to be
but i mean it's like probably like an
hour and 40 because of the credits yeah
but still not only are you introducing a
bunch of characters you're also trying
to introduce a bunch of lore and a
different world
it's a lot you gotta you gotta jam pack
in here
and um yeah after surprise where does my
heart
really belong here and i met at like
70 with each 60 to 70 with each
character and now i'm not 100
invested in any character that's fair
and i think for mortal kombat it's
important to have
at least one you are really latched into
i think it's important to have at least
one
you know because like yeah i think the
visuals are cool and the fighting's cool
and all that jazz and there's some funny
moments and like i said overall i was
i'm still entertained throughout even
when i think it's the only times i get a
little pulled out is when like my
critical brain does kicking
yeah you know it's like as like a silly
popcorn movie i enjoy the hell out of it
but uh it's also not
fully going for that so i think it lends
itself to be criticized on these other
sides as well
it's like you know when you're watching
the movie that guys why are you really
trying to judge this you know what this
movie is
yeah but but this movie i think goes out
of its way to try to be more and that's
where
it can you can be aware of like you're
not succeeding at that
yeah so i'm just a little in the middle
yeah
it gets caught in the middle of being
like like yeah just like a kind of
schlocky action movie that knows how fun
it wants to be
and then also being something of serious
like the crazy
new mystical fantasy landscape world of
mortal kombat
when we only feature a play of
characters and
it's like even like the background
levels on video games you'll see like
characters in the background or [ __ ]
like yeah you know
i'm moving around and yeah yeah and
maybe the training just should have been
more special
other than just generic let's fight and
hope your iconic comes out yeah that's
what it felt like
all right guys well mortal kombat what
did you guys think of this movie
did you overall uh enjoy it 6.8 for me
seven for john leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
check us out patreon and we'll catch you
guys soon thank you for being here
[Music]